[Applause]
the former president and current vice
president of argentina christina
fernandez de kirchner is on trial in the
case that's dividing the nation
the prosecution says she led one of the
biggest corruption syndicates in the
country's history she calls it a
political witch hunt
this trial started with this fiction
that was recounted by the prosecutors
over five days during those five days i
listened to those accusations that were
not accusations they were a fiction a
script a very bad one besides being
false
the prosecution is calling for a 12-year
prison sentence and a lifetime ban on
the vice president holding public office
one opposition politician even demanded
her execution
in response her supporters took to the
streets outside her apartment in buenos
aires police controlled by the
opposition-led city government responded
aggressively provoking strong criticism
from the national government including
the president alberto fernandez
her supporters now keep a daily vigil
outside her home
when you put one of our main political
leaders on trial in such a weak case you
undermine democracy and a lot of blood
has been spilt to win our democracy
she did so much the school the city
metro gave food to the poor equip the
universities and gave a wish to
housewives
christina fernandez de kitchener divides
opinion like no other but this trial is
about much more than whether she's
guilty or not guilty it's about how many
argentines see the future of their
troubled country
a former president the wife of a former
president and now argentina's vice
president mrs kirchner has been around
for long enough to have made plenty of
friends and a lot of enemies
her opponents view the former president
as symbolic of the corruption that's
blighted argentina for generations they
want to prevent her standing again for
president in next year's elections
it will be historic for argentina the
first time a female president convicted
for a fully proven corruption crime let
it serve as an example for all
it gives us hope that we still have
justice in argentina and this has only
just begun
the verdict on christina kitchner and
the 12 other accused is expected later
this year whatever the outcome argentina
will be divided by an increasingly
bitter conflict
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires